hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute habe ich wieder ein super leckere
torten rezept für euch und zwar eine
torte ohne packen also aus dem
kühlschrank einen notweg kuchen und der
kuchen ist wirklich super schnell
zubereitet und ihr braucht auch nur ganz
wenige zutaten dafür hier unten habe ich
einen knusper boden mit schokolade und
löffelbiskuits in der mitte eine
stracciatella creme mit dickmanns und
mit quark und oben habe ich noch eine
frucht schicht mit himbeeren dass
künstler ich mache ja wahrscheinlich
schon viel chemie das würdest du auch
hinkriegen und wir uns erst noch boden-
und ich habe genug und dekoriert habe
ich selbst noch mit den waffeln und ja
am ende dieses videos gibt ein richtig
tolles gewinnspiel da müsst ihr auf
jeden fall bleiben das wird wieder
heftig genau und ich zeige euch jetzt
aber zuerst einmal die zutaten für den
brüssel boden denn den mache ich jetzt
so erst für den knusper boden brauchen
wir 200 gramm kekse oder löffelbiskuits
100 gramm butter 50 g gehackte mandeln
und 50 gramm butter schokolade
jetzt werde ich zuerst einmal die kekse
nehmen und sie zerkleinern
ich mache das jetzt in einem mixer aber
ihr könnt sie auch in einem
gefrierbeutel film und dann einfach mit
einem ausbaustopp drüber rollen dann
sind auch klein
als nächstes nehme ich jetzt die butter
die kommt jetzt in den kleinen topf und
david hsieh geschmolzen und da gebe ich
gleich auch die schokolade mexiko die
schokolade kommt in kleinen stücken mit
akku den herd aber jetzt schon
ausgestellt denn die hitze der mutter
reicht aus um die schokolade zum
schmelzen zu bringen und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal in einer
beschichteten pfanne ohne fett den mann
sind einfach passen damit sie es ein
bisschen aroma bekommen jetzt kann ich
alle zutaten gemeinsam zu den keks
bröseln geben
jetzt vermisse ich alles gut miteinander
jetzt habe ich hier schon mal einen bug
rahmen vorbereitet und zwar als sitzend
ort bringen dann habe ich auf 26 cm
eingestellt und habe ihn auf ein stück
pappe picknick und darunter ist ein
token retter dann kann ich nämlich die
torte gleich gut in den kühlschrank
stellen kinder das backpapier wenn ihr
möchtet gerne auch noch zu schneiden
damit drohen bei über guckt einfach
falten 6 uhr mittel hin
jetzt legt er die mitte hier mit ich auf
standorten retter und könnte sie am rand
entlang schneiden
und dann habt ihr einen fast perfekten
kreis die machtfülle ich jetzt hier mit
rein und drückt sie dann schön mit den
händen oder auch mit dem teig scheibe
oder einem glas platz
die zweite stelle jetzt für 15 minuten
in den gefrierschrank an in der
zwischenzeit schon mal den frucht spiele
herstellen
für den frucht spiegel brauche ich 300
gramm himbeersaft 200 kabinen werden und
ein päckchen agad ihnen magazine das ist
so eine pflanzliche hilfe also praktisch
der gegenteil von gelatine oder die
alternative zusteller tine nämlich den
saft und gebe 200 minimiert sagt davon
in einen kleinen topf den rest da sie
nur über und da kommt jetzt die ak tine
mit rein und die zwei zutaten werden
jetzt miteinander verrührt und dann
lasse ich die mischung jetzt aufkochen
und zwei minuten sprudelnd kochen
es ist auch ganz richtig damit als die
akademie ihre wirkung entfalten kann
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt
schon mal die himbeer nehmen und
zerkleinern
dafür fühle ich jetzt in einen mixer
da kommt der rest sagt mit dass sie
jetzt einfach nur noch gering
die mischung für dich jetzt tritt um und
da kommt jetzt die ak tine mischung mit
rein einfach damit alles jetzt ein
bisschen schneller abkühlt und wird im
buch spiegelt keine himberg gerne haben
möchte da kann sie vorher natürlich auch
durch ein sieb streichen
jetzt kann ich es hier ein bisschen
abkühlen lassen und kann schon mal die
green vorbereiten für die creme traurig
400 milliliter schlagsahne vier
teelöffel seiner part 500 gramm quark
200 frischkäse etwas an extrakt und eine
bio zitrone dann nochmal 15 teelöffel
sabbath und zwölf bands zuerst einmal
nämlich auf die sahne und schlagt sie
steif und die wird es zuerst kurz da
wird dann kommt sein apartment rein und
damit sie richtig steif gerührt
die sahne wird steif geschlagen und
bleibt auch schon in der schüssel drin
jetzt habe ich hier von bereits 150
gramm sahne weg gelegt für die
dekoration und werde jetzt beide sahen
einfach in den kühlschrank stellen
diese steht jetzt kurz im kühlschrank
und jetzt können wir hier schon mal die
cvag creme verrühren
also einfach alle zutaten hier rein und
dann ab hat kommt noch mit rein und ich
kann schon mal die schale der bio
zitrone abreiben also sollte auf jeden
fall eine zitrone nehmen deren schale
unbehandelt ist jetzt kommen etwa drei
teelöffel zitronensaft mit rein
die creme mit jetzt kurz verrührt bis
sie alle zutaten verbunden sind
jetzt stelle ich sie kurz zur seite und
nehmen schon mal die big man ja
jetzt rede ich die dickmanns von der
waffe ab und hebt die waffel aber für
die dekoration auf
jetzt wird die creme noch mit den dick
männern verrührt mit männern die creme
noch mit den dickmanns verrührt
ich habe hier diese leckere dickmanns
creme da wird von auf die sahne
untergehoben schmeckt es auch richtig
schön frisch durch die dickmanns durch
die zitrone durch den zitronen abrieb
und das wird in der torte später als
lecker die creme wird jetzt auf dem
torten wurden verteilt
jetzt freilich die creme schön glatt
und jetzt verteile ich den lauwarm und
fruchtspieße über die creme
und jetzt muss die torte für etwa vier
stunden in den kühlschrank sie
dekorieren und feststellen kann
die torte sind gut durch gekühlt und
jetzt kann ich sie bereits herausnehmen
und dekorieren
dafür gehe ich hier mit einem tortenring
messer am rand entlang
jetzt setzt sich die torte auf eine
tortenplatte es geht mit dem töten
retter immer ganz gut und das backpapier
das können wir jetzt so unverwechselbar
und schlagen
jetzt nehme ich die sahne die ich vorher
schon zurückgelegt hatte und kann jetzt
hier zwölf top four auf die torte
spritzen
jetzt nehme ich die dickmanns waffe und
die könnte jetzt im prinzip so drauf
setzen oder wenn sie euch zu groß sind
einfach nur halbieren
ich werde jetzt einfach einen kleineren
kreis ausstechen und zum runden aus
stechert
wird lediglich noch die waffeln als
dekoration obendrauf jetzt die torte
fertig und darf gleich probiert werden
die torte ist jetzt gut durch gekühlt
und du darfst jetzt probieren
ich hab doch schon die ganze zeit sie
muss ehrlich sagen ich habe heute nichts
gegessen wenn ich irgendwie heute morgen
ganz am tricks war und jetzt bin ich
richtig scharf die top ten als erste was
ich heute esse dann einfach nur 26
sekunden dann ist der weg also erstmal
hier so sieht sie aus
das ist diese frucht einlagen mit mir
sucht einlagen seien also braucht flogen
kurz spiel genau hier die ganze diese
dickmanns creme und dieser kranz boden
also wer das macht macht ihm und
sprunger ist für mich das leckerste
richtiger cola auf jeden fall frisch
extrem knusprig und richtig lecker
wirklich und vor allem diese süße von
eleganz mit dem 5 mit dem mit der frucht
einlage spiegel wie auch immer frucht
einfach richtig lecker vor allem finde
ich dort auch optisch sehr hübsch also
diese drei komponenten passen auch
optisch wirklich sehr gut zusammen ja
gleich ab jetzt auch lust auf dieses
rezept bekommen dann könnt ihr auf
sallys blog.de und ich würde sagen wir
gehen gleich zum gewinnspiel
endlich ist fertig ich sehe mich ja
jetzt kommen wir zum gewinnspiel und
zwar so dickmanns deutschland zufall
egger wecker mitmachen könnt ihr beim
gewinnspiel in dem ihr eine eigene bad
kreation mit den dickmanns entwickeln
und zwar gibt es 300 mal dass dickmanns
reisen zu gewinnen und fünf hauptpreise
und zwar kommt europa kreation in das
dickmanns packt
auch und ihr könnt eine von fünf kitchen
küchenmaschinen gewinnen jetzt könnt ihr
euer rezept entwickeln und dieses auf
dickmanns de hochladen mit rezept und
foto und einsendeschluss ist der 14
und die dickmanns jury wird dann am ende
die gewinner ermitteln und ich wünsche
euch auf jeden fall schon mal ganz viel
spaß beim backen beim nachbacken meines
rezept beim entwickeln ihre eigenen
rezepte und ich wünsche euch natürlich
ganz viel kreativität und ganz viel
glück
also viel spaß und bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss